from what I saw in your book on Amazon
when I was going through you said that
you didn't have relatives in the
industry you had very supportive parents
and you had to break in what you call
the old-fashioned way which was hard
work discipline and faith and I was
wondering for you talk about the faith
part what is that exactly this is a if
you don't believe in yourself why why do
you expect other people to believe in
you and it's your dream someone else
will live their dream and why shouldn't
you live your dream that was always my
opinion and it's scary because you don't
know if you're going to or they will
allow you to do it so you have to write
something that you care about but also
that somebody else sees you know that
care in there and wants to make it then
then the business part becomes they want
to invest millions of dollars and your
idea as opposed to somebody else's idea
and it's finding that company it's the
timing finding my spec sold because my
first and only spec which was my fifth
spec but that opened the door for
assignment work so I haven't sold a spec
since then because I've been blessed
with assignment work which is fine I've
written other specs yes but it's
exhausting to try to continue it's you
know this one maybe this one it's much
you know it's it's a much better
experience when the producer comes to me
and says are you available we have this
concept that's greenlit we need a writer
you're like thank you very much
you know I I would love the job I'm
available I've turned down stuff as well
but the faith aspect you always have to
have faith not blind faith but there are
times when you're staring into that dark
abyss and you go I'm gonna take the leap
you know like when I worked a day job at
the law firm you know I only had a day
job for two years in my whole life you
know I worked other odd jobs like
restaurants and things but once I was I
decided to take that day job because
things were really slow in my career
when I got the call from the production
company and they said we have this job
we want to get back in
business with you I took that leap now
wasn't the void wasn't so dark because
it was a job it was money but I could
have thought about it and said well I'll
stay at the firm because it's steady
money and I'll do this other job you
know and I can do both right because I
have and it wasn't worth it for me to do
that I was doing the minute they said
hang up that phone a two-week notice I
took that leap because I just need to do
that I have to live the life of a writer
you know and and luckily the X less X
number of years I'd been able to do that
live the life where I get up and that's
the only thing I do that's my job and
it's you know the faith aspect like I
said as we discussed before you always
have to have people who believe in you
but that only goes so far they can all
yeah you know right you're the best you
know oh that's why I say don't give your
script to your family members to read
because unless they're executives at
Warner Brothers because I there's no
real point in it you know everybody's
gonna say that's the best thing ever
well it kept my interest you know if
you're great so everybody can rally
around you and say yeah and have the
faith but it comes down you're living
you're living it you know you're sitting
in front of the computer you're trying
to come up with ideas and your your
choices that you make are directly
affecting your life financially and
psychologically and you know
relationship wise with other people so
there's a lot of things involved about
pursuing a screenwriting career not just
so I'm gonna write a script you know
there's a bigger picture about how it
affects you to life especially when it
becomes how you pay your bills so faith
is an important part but you have to
there's always a fear still I mean when
I get a new job I get nervous you know I
think I read that Henry Fonda would
throw up on stage before he went out to
do a performance you're like you're
hitting me Fonda but I think a little of
that nervous not too much fear but that
like respects that's where the respect
for me comes into the craft where I sit
down I go
and my mama says oh you'll know what to
do you're fine you know to this day she
says that I go I think I'm fine
but I I'm pretty sure I'm fine and then
yeah I finish it and I go yeah okay but
I don't want to have that arrogance of
like I'll work it in this is fine no no
no absolutely not so um I have a
tremendous faith in my ability but I
temper it with humility and also the
realities of the business and and you
know just situations I guess so faith is
the back your question is extremely
important but I think it faith in
yourself first and foremost don't search
outward for it you know like looking
looking for validation from outside to
get that you know like oh I'll write
something and if somebody an agent likes
it then that validates me you know no no
and have faith in your abilities first
and foremost and then go out there and
see what happens
that's gratitude always been a part of
your makeup I see that gratitude seems
to be a strong thing for you but maybe
I'm wrong has it always been in your
nature mean gratitude
seems like you you recognize yes but
also the longer you're in the business
you you it always has been my makeup yes
but the longer you get punched around
and and see how things work for myself
everybody has a different story you you
are very humbled and gracious and then
you say things like I'm blessed yes I
feel that I'm blessed but I also have
done a lot of hard work and a tremendous
amount of sacrifice in my life to devote
to this and not for the sake of being
you know the wealth and the riches and
the loot you know because there is no I
say there's no fame and fortune in the
screenwriting game I mean you know it's
it's when you have most half of the
writers in the writers guild don't don't
work every year and those are
professional WG writers I think the odds
last year like 5,000 200 or something
out of approximately 10,000 so the other
half
are looking for jobs and not working you
know or the 50,000 scripts there
apparently registered with the guild
every year those are just the ones
registered or the 70 to 100 specs a year
this cell you know I always tell writers
I don't bring up those odds to scare you
but for you to realize what you're up
against you know you wouldn't go climb
Mount Everest without the training and
the help and the tools you just go okay
I'm gonna go do it now there's a certain
courage in doing that but there's also a
certain stupidity at some time you know
and just like writing your script and
being eager and someone says oh I want
to read it you give it to the wrong
person and then that bad note circulates
you're finished you know I mean they're
things like that so yeah with this job
at the law firm so you got this movie or
you got some other show or something did
you did that pan out no it was made it
was made okay I went to the set while I
was working and that was the that was
the hardest part where I'm like I don't
want to go back and then I had to go
back he even you know I'm like I'm deja
vu I'm back in the situation I was
however many years before with with you
know doing the catering when I sold my
first spec because the way monies are
doled out in the step deal you just
because it's option or whatever it
doesn't mean you can quit your job and
live in Bel Air you know so there's the
realities about paying your bills so
it's same thing when I was working at
the day job but again I was like it
starts to psychologically work and you
say no but I'm a writer it's a yeah you
work at a thing and I'm back in the
tunnel again I'm you know and there was
another writer there who was a sitcom
writer and he had worked on things and
he to hit a short thing and you know
short I mean a young a slow period and
he was he was on his way to get back to
and he did too we all sort of quit at
the same time and he got back in their
writing sitcoms and I was like yeah you
know no looking back and I don't know
it's just there's now again you know I I
don't have you know children you know so
I you know that family aspect is a whole
different you know thing so what I say
is from my own opinion that means from
my own experience
but it sort of it sort of goes for
everyone you know with with disciplines
and things you have to really keep your
eye on the prize and the big picture as
I say because you can get lost so easily
even when you're in it and doing it you
can get lost you know so you always have
to have to have that bigger plan but
where am I going with my career what am
i doing you know
you